it's time for screen junkies movie
fights
hoot hoot owl nation
here are my Birds at what's up guys
welcome to movie fights I am NOT a
member of validation that's why you know
that that was a terrible terrible owl
nation attempt I'm Joestar Hal Rudnick
is stuck in traffic he'll be here in
like 15-20 minutes welcome back to movie
fights we've got a huge all summer all
hit all home runs no filler all killer
lineup look at this panel of fighters
holy crap it's Mark Ellis Good Feet well
knew how this is gonna be a fun show I
am very excited about this for a number
of reasons
how spent certain the other guy but
here's why I'm most pumped about this I
think I might have the hottest take in
the history of movie fights in one of
these guys steamy hot takes racing this
ya know if you stay tuned for nothing
else besides me how Rudnik turn it for
this it's very very hot before we meet
these other two jabronis because people
know him let me read the plug that you
yourself wrote on my page in your
beautiful hand Mark Ellis big show at
The Comedy Store on Sunset September 12
this Thursday tell me lots of big names
like me how rudnick oh no no it was
booked on the show he's not on the show
you can grab tickets at Mark Ellis comm
everyone comes live Mark Ellis live.com
guys I almost said org every one of
these Mark Ellis and French shows you
put on our fantastic
you uh you joined us it's a lot of fun I
was the low point but even at that point
it was still a very good show that's
what kind of value were talking about
the mustache you didn't have the rest of
the facial hair so no yes figure things
out yeah yeah yeah
but it was really exciting so yeah a lot
of big drop in since the Comedy Store on
Sunset you never know who's gonna show
up and I'm on the show kidnaps like a
great drunk movie fighter he's gonna be
on the show Candice Thompson from The
Tonight Show Matt knows very funny and
then you know some special surprise it's
gonna be a good choice peaking special
surprises let's meet these other two
fighters what a surprise I'm amazed we
got you guys Jake Gilbert Dan Merle
welcome to the show hi Thank You pal
yeah Harold I don't care what they're
saying about you online about your
comments about the Jews and the Muslims
you're never canceled in my book and
congrats on the wedding by the way oh no
I thank you very much we're very happy
fantastic honeymoon and just really
excited to set up our lives together
yeah I follow you on Instagram the
filter the use a little different just
being right here next to the man still
working on the filters yeah yeah it's
either gang over Nashville that best
brings out huh yeah yeah speaking of
gingham in Nashville it's over in the
couch its London Calling its lon
Harrison Daniel Radford and whoever just
ran by the camera frame we do the show
monthly now that means we forget had a
dual operation we gotta go max lon
Harris has to go and that's how that
just ran by
he has officially quit and typically
she's the voice of the people but we
have not given the people of voice this
episode so she's just our beautiful
judge number three Daniel Radford you
always have a voice with me people that
is a cut song from the new Aladdin movie
you know my favorite thing about the new
thing with movie fights since we've gone
monthly is having more time to plan and
pre-tape really takes the chaos out of
date yeah we did it was to make this
show easier to produce and execute and
I'm glad we've gotten off to such an
orderly start we had a month to set this
up yeah and I feel so prepared I feel
refreshed yeah yeah I got not 11 minutes
ago to be here at the studio for it
myself and do my cryotherapy all of the
nathan i usually do to prepare for an
argument against two of the greatest in
the business i feel very ready yeah
we're a well-oiled machine here but it's
like the end of snowpiercer where the
machine is actually small children feels
like we planned a surprise birthday
party and then forgot we were gonna do
the surprise birthday party and then the
guest minute 20 without starting the
show yeah that's classic movie fights
feelings and that means we're going back
to classic movie fights rules not only
are you three fighters that aren't
standing like a bunch of morons
we're going back to five main round
watched it set up to five speed round
question you guys wanted the show to be
really long again we're giving you a
show that's really long again
demanded see all of that hey settle in
enough enough of my time wasting hoping
that how will show up to actually host
this is let invite what is Phi Buster's
[Music]
Thank You let's do it again
let's start the show for God's sakes
please something I've wanted to say my
entire screen junkies career thank you
for thank you for question number one
let's do it ring that Bell I don't know
if we still have the sound effect Bell
or if we actually have to say this at
the front desk with question number one
very small question gentlemen what's the
best movie of summer 2019 yes no summer
officially began in May till Labor Day
summer is when the pool when the
community pool opens for the very first
time yep
that is when summer begin yeah may
whatever that is first weekend of May
yeah we're currently in Halloween season
looking back at summer so mark Ellis I
asked you what's the best movie of
summer 2019 it's a good question how I
mean look because Avengers end game try
as they might Marvel and Disney they
tried to alter time with their stones
but they can't do it and place Avengers
end game into the summer so we have to
pick something else
don't worry faithful viewer the home
watcher I figured out the best movie
this summer it's got comedy it's got
action it's got bananas all over the
place and it's a really funny
heartwarming story good boys is the best
movie of the summer it is hilarious it
was unexpected aren't the best movies
the ones that you didn't know we're
coming out then you see some crazy
trailer and go oh my god I gotta go see
this I like the producer Seth Rogen and
Evan Goldberg you then those three kids
look like they have some potty mouths
and it's not just bad humor and and bad
the kids saying bad words for the sake
of shock value it really has a lot of
nice emotional content through there I
think it helps kids adapt to whatever
they're going through school is back in
session
good boys is one of the reasons why I am
happy to say I lived through sixth grade
I had all of those things go on in my
own live I think everybody did it's a
very relatable movie and for that reason
it's the best of the summer you want to
feel good when you go to the movie
theater that's what good boys does good
boys make you feel good that was a weird
sense
yeah well it's best to move your summer
2019 B I think that it's already a
pretty easy choice I think far and away
the best movie the summer is j-dub Trey
John wick three parable um it is so good
this is a movie that cemented John wick
as the best action France franchise of
I'd say the Millennium is everything you
want out of a John wick movie and it
keeps managing to up the ante this is a
movie where John wick murders a giant
with a library book and then there's a
hundred and twenty minutes left he kills
people with two horses they just find
the most creative ways to without
resorting to CG without resorting to
contrived melodrama all the other tricks
that franchises fall into they managed
to keep it fresh but keep it essentially
wick and keepers come back for more
well said champ I'm going with a movie
that came out from one of the most
interesting directors working today
Quentin Tarantino's Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood I think was the best movie of
the summer it was pure cinema it was I
love when a movie comes out that it's
not just a movie it's it's a cinematic
experience and that's what Quentin
Tarantino put together it is a movie
about movies which i think is a fun
thing to do in the summer it's not a
Western it's not something like that
it's about Hollywood it's about big
blockbuster movie making and it's a
fantasy I don't want to go too far into
spoilers for the movie but I love the
fact that a lot of people were kind of
worried about how is this gonna be
tinged by these real-life events that
were very horrific that happened and
Quentin Tarantino found a way to make a
movie about movie set in this era that
evokes that era that that transports you
to that era but then is also able to use
that real life those real lives event
events in a way that it's both extremely
satisfying but at the same time poignant
at the same time very bittersweet and
and really ties the whole movie and its
themes together at the end I think that
this was one of the most interesting
movies I've seen in a long time and it's
one that I'm gonna
- for years and years which i think is
the mark of a great movie that I can't
wait to see it again
to go back to find new things to
experience it again I think it was the
movie-going experience of the summer hey
boys movie fight you know how when we
really want to go watch a movie again
and it's cinema Dan we don't called
watch again we say revisit that's what
you say when you're talking about a
really great film watch it again you
have to remove this don't worry watch
Yuri watch good boys visit Once Upon a
dog dare cross good boys because like
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood there's a
lot of great elements of it it's like
it's like I'm looking at a guinea pig
cage and you dress it up really nice and
you put some cool cars and and some neat
costumes but the one problem itself is
dead there's no there's nothing there
there's no story there it just took some
real life events and it did the same
switcheroo that we already saw with
inglorious basterds and Spencer that's a
perfect analogy mark thank you not
transfer to John wig Parabellum because
there's a lot of great action there but
it's just another John wick movie we
thought we were getting the closes great
trilogy and in the end the movie got so
desperate that it had to tell you all
the way maybe there is no thank God
there is because there are questions
that remained unanswered and knives that
remain to be thrown at each other I have
to kind of take myself out of the the
once upon time and Hollywood thing
because I thought that movie was great
but that movie is like catnip for the
Sinha file if it was specifically the
older cinephile living in Los Angeles
who can look at that and be like oh my
god that is what Hollywood was like in
the 70s and you know how old do you
think I am yeah you're cold
I wasn't alive during the 1969 you have
you have the same vibe as a Brad Pitt in
the in the bathrobe you know yelling at
people on Islam that's our catnip thank
you yes that is this is a film that is
not universally accessible I think that
the people who came expecting Kill Bill
okay I'm expecting even Pulp Fiction
left disappointed because it's like two
hours of guys driving around in cars
reminiscing and talking about the movie
business and then a crazy ending well I
don't think it's a movie it defies
expectations that makes it a night of
bad movies but if I could makes it more
interesting movie and I hate it I keep
getting this idea every time I talk
about something invest and somebody
comes back to me says like well it's not
accessible to everybody so it can't be
the best that it's both
I'm sorry stuff is not the stuff that's
the most accessible to anybody it's not
in fact that's usually the worst stuff I
disagree I think it's harder to make
something that genuinely appeals to
every person who comes to see you were
not walking at John wick three without
going oh my gosh I must revisit that I
did I I walked out of John wick three in
a position that I didn't think that I
would be in which is not that exciting
motorcycle versus no not being that
excited for another John wick movie I've
got a behind this I love the first two
John wick movies and you're right this
has a lot of great scenes in John wick
chapter three but by the time we got to
the end of it we've gone to such a place
it's just like I thought we were
wrapping it up and I'm like that's great
because John wick has shown me
everything and I want to see this story
end
okay you got to the end of it was like
that but note there might be the period
for the story regardless I'm ready for
the story Spencer that's part of making
sure the clothes should have been the
clothes to agree at the end of a great
trilogy Spencer we want to see he walks
high-fiving pilots
Walmart picture wrap up we don't want to
pay but we might come that's Maze Runner
stuff man
it's like historic intimacy but maybe we
got something else down the road look
there there's nothing harder in the
world of in Danza lexicon cinema there's
nothing harder to do then make it
audience Lab it's very easy to bore the
crap out of them with your own ego trip
watching Quentin Tarantino stroke
himself for two and a half hours that's
an easy thing to do there's a lot of
great action 70s there's a lot of cool
stunts in John wig three but it is so
hard to make an audience laugh
particularly when you have little kids
can they pull off these characters but
still relate to kids and adults alike
that's why good boys was so magnificent
transcendent it took some of the Roth's
you get from American Pie or pork these
are super bad but it combined it with a
heart that you get in the best
coming-of-age films well I can stand by
me or like a breakfast club it mouths
kids that actually have a heart at the
end has been a trope since the Little
Rascals this has been good since super
bad it worked in book-smart even better
this summer but fighting people has
never been done before not like I'm
better in two other John Waite movie
when have you seen two guys from the
raid kick Keanu Reeves ass and then
pause before they could kill him because
they want to keep fighting that is an
action movie first
I live on Hollywood and Vine you see
that nightly and by the way I was stuck
in traffic for 20 minutes when they were
filming the scene and once upon a time
of them driving in Hollywood so you may
say sixth look I was in my 2018 Ford
Fusion did not make the final cut good
boys is the second-best version of a
second-rate super bad that came out this
summer he's I agree book-smart was a
better version of super bad than good
voice was which was also pretty much a
version of super bad I liked it I liked
the movie I thought it was funny but if
I'm looking at the best movie of the
summer like it's it was it had last but
make you know I didn't laugh all I have
to do is fart it's not that hard my body
literally does it on my own
like right now if you fart on this show
then you know I'm gonna do in a month
I'm gonna revisit this episode I yeah
good boys it's fine but I think that
when you look at a movie that you're
gonna call the best movie of the summer
it's something that has to stand apart
from the pack John with chapter three is
a good action movie but I don't think
it's the best John wick movie and I
think it's a rather sorry big spectacle
movies that did well just summer it's
the kind of spectacle is the spectacle
where two dogs murder an entire black
ops unit sent by Halle Berry doing her
best acting spinning all this in your
phone votes yeah final thought is yes I
did come to the end of this well done
how well done I came to the end of his
message and I was skeptical about John
wick for but that is not because John
wick 3 wasn't so good sorry for the
swear that was because I thought how
could they possibly top John wick 3 we
need to appreciate this movie in its
time Keanu is giving us his everything
this franchise is giving us it's
everything we need to appreciate it
before his body falls apart like Tom
Cruise mm-hmm how I feel like a movie
that stands away from the rest of the
pack does not necessarily make it a
great movie it just separates the live
guinea pigs from the one dead one that
nobody should take money at the end of
the day with Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood just because it's different
than every other movie does not make it
better the fact that good boys feels
like a lot of different movies and it's
just better than those I think makes it
elevated in this discussion now as far
as Spencer goes I think that the
Dobermans used in John wig 3 that's a
stereotype against Dobermans people diss
look at them as these evil menacing dogs
and Dobermans are very cute they were
very cuddly we're only only on command
it's a it was like a I'm not gonna make
a gun control
it's Walmart stop selling government
they're saying the good boys is the
second funniest movie the second best
coming-of-age movie this summer I would
take that over the eighth best Tarantino
movie or the third best John wick movie
mind you there's only been three made so
far who dan I'm sorry that you didn't
like once upon a time in Hollywood I did
and I don't think that it is the eighth
best Quentin Tarantino movies the
nightmares like it's one of my more
favorite Quentin Tarantino movies III
I'm sorry that you looked at that movie
and saw a dead guinea pig I did not I
saw a vibrant page it will have so many
different guinea pigs with everything
Aryan Khan stays with their feet out
every time I go look at that cage I'm
gonna look at those guinea pig feet and
I'm gonna look at those guinea pig
set-dressing
and I'm gonna find a new guinea pig and
something new to appreciate in that cage
every time I go for it that's another
thing I think makes a movie great is
everybody looks at it and they see
something different I looked at good
boys and I saw a average - a slightly
above-average comedy that I would lump
in there with several other comedies
that came out in the summer when I see
John wick chapter 3 I see another entry
in an action franchise that I definitely
enjoy but it felt a little long in the
tooth to me I was hoping it was gonna
give me a satisfying conclusion it did
not give me a satisfying conclusion once
upon a time in Hollywood was a meal and
a half and dessert and by the way you
get a doggie bag to take home I think it
was a it was a cinematic feast and I was
there for every minute of time all right
boys a lot of uh it's gonna be back a
lot of a lot of senses I've never a lot
of words I've never heard strung
together before I own metaphors used
against me
okay my thoughts taken long we got any
facts that need to get a looked at
Colfax those are actually not Dobermans
in John we three their garages and Marin
wha
Greek loosely really
okay okay with the dogs in car accessory
accessories I was not alive in the
spirit of a much older man I don't think
anyone's dispute again I'm accusing Dan
as being old right now and I'm not
Danielle yes where's your heart right
now what you thinking what's your vote I
have so many thoughts there were a lot
of analogies here
I don't know how guinea pigs work
anymore I thought I did that's fine
great fight first of all everyone was
fantastic you were all pain popping off
of each other very very well this was
the Battle of the stretched analogy and
they were they were all fantastic I wish
I heard a little bit more about John
wick 3 itself and not so much about what
this potential sequel for John wick 3
was I have to say I'm literally just
basing it on all of the analogies at the
end then put together the most coherent
one with the thing about food which
would be eaten in the way that food is
eaten and not hamsters in guinea pigs in
dresses or whatever so I couldn't cope
with Dickens because that's what you
guys gave me gains at the buffets on the
board that's one lon Mark came out with
a really strong point
opening about good boys is really strong
and I thought his raunch plus heart sort
of arguing was really good but that I
thought dad it Spencer really got him
pretty good with that's the formula
that's the trope we're kind of used to
and then book-smart
also coming out this summer being
another strong entry in the same genre I
think that really took him out so it
came down to Dan versus Spencer to me
and yeah I agree with Daniella I thought
it's supposed to made a lot of good
arguments but got kind of sidetracked by
the John wick as a as an entry and a
larger franchise as opposed to making
the case for John wick 3 itself
ultimately I thought dan make just had
the most to say and the most compelling
arguments that weren't answered about
his movie so I'm going with that hmm dan
you're taking this one yeah you know my
vote here doesn't really matter but I
gotta say egg as the man who's much
better at doing this than I am would say
great moment in sports the guinea pig
analogy joestar's not that much better
at this than you might say worse but you
you did you did have the point simply
because you know in the beach volleyball
world of guinea pig analogies he set it
up he spiked it and you sent it right
back which I was I did not see coming
there's a reason why you're the champ I
would've given it to you - Dan so
Danvers point on the board is that
Hollywood he'll Rudnick's music let me
bring this man to the stage right now
he's a legend in the space he's the
reason I have a job here he's a he's a
dear friend I love him a lot he's a good
boy he's a good boy
he is very book smart nobody's guinea
pig he is Parabellum he's how Rudnick
ladies and gentlemen my special effects
during this taping or wordy ageing Merle
to look like a 36 year old man that
showgirls on Estrela I got to live my
dream of how Rudnick Pastis existing in
the world and all right guys wow this is
a great moment in sports all right John
wig so ARMA sets these furry creatures I
have Christ look I feel refreshed
because I feel like I was in Vegas at
the blackjack dealer and I lost a hand
and I don't really like the way the
dealer spent but now we got a new dealer
in there and it's a new movie fights
hashtag owl nation everybody welcome to
movie fights that first question let's
throw it in the trash let's start you
know it counts all right here we go um
you guys so it's Dan one Spencer zero
mark zero looking to get on the board
glad to be here lon Dan calling great to
see uh well let's jump it around - all
right so we just addressed the question
what is the best movie of 2019 thus far
now let's posit the question what's the
worst movie of summer 2019 there it is
and it's question number two so let's
start with the player number two Spencer
Gilbert yeah this is the x-men dork
Phoenix who boy this one storks added
this film it was like the x-men died and
the cast of the x-men showed up to the
funeral and they taped it and released
it as a feature film this is the joyless
dour slipshod crap version of the x-men
we've seen that's saying something I
have ever so much more to say about it
but I think I will hold back until I
hear Marc's petition is it mine no it's
uh it's it's Dan's trochus yes at least
your joyless movie had dark in the title
mine was joyless but full of things that
should have given everyone joy my
biggest men in black international good
grief what a waste of talent of
everything you could possibly imagine in
this movie i sat through it it got to
the end of it and I realize I hadn't
cracked a smile once the the the action
scenes were completely inert which is
unbelievable considering that F gary
Gray directed this movie and say what
you will about things like the you know
the fast and furious movies the more
recent ones but the one thing they never
were were boring and inert and devoid of
any interesting action I mean he has
such a propulsive filmmaker and the fact
that you haven't direct him in and like
international with no energy or joy to
it whatsoever you have Chris Hemsworth's
and Tessa Thompson two of our more
charismatic actors we've seen how good
they are on screen together before and
for eggnog no charisma give Kumail
Nanjiani
nothing Rebecca Ferguson nothing just a
complete waste of everything of all the
talent on display there and that's why
it's my worst in the summer all right
thank you Dan Marc Ellis how history is
littered with that time in a celebrity's
life when they went crazy you have your
your Gary Busey's your Nicolas Cage's
your Mel Gibson so you're gonna hear my
answer you say hey it was all Mark Ellis
drinkin and moon shadows in Malibu
before he came over here today that Mark
Ellis gets taken down a peg the answer's
no although my opinion is gonna be
controversial because the question is
what is the worst movie of the summer
2019 and that question was posited in
early September this might not have been
my answer a month ago this might not be
Maya's or eight months from now
ever as it currently stands in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe with
spider-man no longer being welcomed to
the party the worst movie of the summer
is spider-man far from home Wow this
movie sets up a world where spider-man
is taking the reins from mr. Tony Stark
and we're gonna go off the phase for and
have a bunch new adventures with this
guy leaving us and then wouldn't you
know it
real-life intrudes legal debates ensue
producer credits don't get given and
spider-man is now out of the MCU so that
entire movie was a wasted exercise in
setting up spider-man to be in more
movies now they may work out a deal and
I could take some of this back and as it
stands right now we just got a movie
that is two hours of promising of
something that will definitely not
happen as of today in the MCU on top of
the fact that the movie was alright mark
you know I have to say the internet
collectively gasped when they their
answer but now we see of a method to
your madness we shall see fight it out
everybody spritely far from home is I
first of all I thought was a really
enjoyable movie another snap what you
fighting on but I also think that
nothing about the off the current
off-screen negotiations which may or may
not reflect the future of spider-man is
three to five years should have any
bearing on the movie as it stands and
secondly this whole thing about the set
up that still can't pay off I disagree
with that the most exciting developments
that were set up for spider-man didn't
have anything to do with the MCU I
didn't think I thought it was all about
yeah I want to get too far either Parker
but but all about spider-man the
character and Peter Parker the character
and where he goes not you know he didn't
like you know landed Avengers at
headquarters and be like hey I'm an
Avenger now let's go rest as a Marvel
team and to add on to that nothing
that's been announced so far and his
spider-man dependent the face for stuff
is like does he have to be in Black
Panther - no does he have to be in the
Eternals shang-chi like that doesn't
need spider-man to work no they don't
initially but we have a hero that is a
bankable star that we get nothing of you
don't feel the slightest bit Duke this
entire movie was not a standalone
spider-man movie this was a movie that
says firmly hey spider-man is not only
innocent in the MCU he's gonna be lead
the charge in the face pork and on top
of that we get this villain that was the
worst bait and switch in history with
Jake Gyllenhaal's Mysterio Dorf goes
fishing has better baits and switches
than what we got with mr. we all knew he
was a bad guy when he shows up so we
have to put up a dresser a nerd
everybody could tell there was gonna be
something else to this character and
what is his supervillain power
how does he defeat the best earth has to
offer special effects it was better when
it was Brian Brown and Brian Dennehy and
FX 1 & 2 that's a movie about special
effects working this was just a tired
film that now has it's bankable star out
of the entire galaxy and I want my money
back I don't you're saying it's tight
but it seems like your main problem is
that you liked it so much you're upset
that you won't get to see it pay off
later you won't get to see the
continuation of the movie as it stands
today I wanted spider-man in the MCU we
didn't get it you can't say that about
the men in Black's you gotta say that
yet you might not get it but you got it
as it stands today I am a broken-hearted
child that wanted more spider-man and I
didn't get it how that did not happen in
men and boy we could have other men in
black adventures we could have other
adventures ahead Sangam and adventures
we're always Tom Holland but in the same
cast maybe the same director and the
same writers it just might not have had
an gentlemen's agreement to ignore mark
for now on blasting the base which is
Mysterio I thought was great because it
was a double beta switch because yes
everybody knew going in that he was the
villain but then it was a double switch
because they reveal the tie to what it
had and that was what allowed spider-man
to complete his arc because it was all
about coming to terms with Tony Stark's
legacy including Mysterio and by closing
that loop they did another if I had my
druthers what I want him to continue
sure but they close that loop in this
movie the emotions under the age of
seven he says if I had my druthers you
are this is a hot this 36
which was established earlier again
let's talk about Dark Phoenix yes please
Simon Kinberg should be in prison not
movie prison real prison where you get
hit in the head with a tube sock full of
soap flash to our low ships at sea x-men
movie falls flat on its face what a
shocker
that's only happens five or six times is
it for that's so much more egregious
because this is a guy who had a chance
with the last stand to tell the dark
phoenix story he's like guys I'm sorry
I saw everything that went wrong I got
it this time and again like Lucy with
the football except there's no football
and she's just punching Charlie Brown in
the groin and he keeps signing up for
more growing punches I don't know where
that it no no I'm not helping me with
this one but I've just got guinea pig
Dark Phoenix was a poor little orphan
child Dark Phoenix was left out on the
few hundred million dollars when their
studios bought and ever and they
realized that puppet is Papa Mickey
didn't want them it's okay can you blame
it that maybe it wasn't a perfect movie
isn't that a sadder result though of all
these people just dead men walking just
waiting for the movie to end at least
men in black they their charisma was you
know pissing into the ocean and failing
but at least they were trying to make
something but presenter hires his own
dialogue writer he's like I want this
movie to work I don't want this to be a
failure everybody else in x-men dark
phase could not wait to get out of there
well yeah I know that's what I mean it's
like that's not really said if they gave
up on it the studio gave up on it then
that's kind of what you would expect as
opposed to like let him like
international everybody there was trying
their hardest it'll try terrible no it's
nothing it's worse than watching people
try so hard to be funny and charismatic
and it just sits there on the screen
it's depressing in a way the dark
phoenix is not oh face is depressing the
whole thing is a series of revelations
that someone has died and they just
stand her and go gene is dead Raven is
dead Oh magneto he might be dead
hang out with venom who can't wait for
that one that movie's gonna be a turd
rolling in the wind and we had
spider-man look Dark Phoenix is a bad
movie and men in black International is
a bad movie but you write at least they
put forth an effort and at least with
Dark Phoenix they were closing up
mercifully they were putting this thing
to sleep with spider-man they came out
and they they made this huge
announcement that they'll now they have
to renege on this is like a turtle
Sunshine of the spotless mind situation
you had this hot girlfriend and now no
longer enjoying the the hangout she's
done she's moved on she's going
somewhere else and I think that if you
could have your druthers you would say
remove that chip from my brain and the
MCU would want to do over I'm trying to
follow that in algae - so wait this
there's other there's other girls in the
MCU there's there's black widow spider
is the most attractive girlfriend but
there's plenty of other MCU people who
can take on the mantle of the do you
hear the crowd go crazy at the end of
endgame when spider-man shows up again
they were happy for going crazy for
everything or came out looking like the
bow ski they clapped when Thanos took a
dump they clapped at every stupid moment
for the save spider-man for the headline
away look I'm back I'm spider-man I'm
the one that's gonna take it through
phase four
you were never promised that with Dark
Phoenix Dark Phoenix it's you know what
how I am honestly now they were planning
a trilogy on Phoenix it's got made
because Dark Phoenix is on the shelf for
a while they had to do a bunch of
reshoots just the fact that this ragtag
group of mutants could come together and
put together two hours of anything on
celluloid is a bag to people a ragtag
group tried to put together everything
anything on celluloid there was a fight
sequence about crossing the street the
whole third act was about a train
because it was too similar to Captain
Marvel so like a train sure that'll work
they they the whole movie revolves
around Jean Grey and who she really is
and she's the gene we know or love we
don't know Jean Grey she showed up in
Apocalypse was like hi I'm Jean Grey and
then it was over then we have no idea
who this character was about they flub
the whole thing again Simon Kinberg I
guess I don't know why he was directing
us he was directing around along
he's been around long enough so it's his
turn and they're like okay might as well
tip if you're gonna start directing
don't start with the multi hundred
million dollar superhero franchise film
it turns out that there's people sort of
need to know what they're doing
otherwise everyone just stands around
straining looking like absolute [ __ ]
hoping that the CGI will come save them
later and make them look cool it doesn't
the whole film is just a series of
imagine that for a hundred and forty
minutes yeah people trying to go to the
bathroom bones and 40 minutes thank you
Spencer Dan this disappointment in a
long string of disappointments from the
x-men franchise it's no surprise that
they that they whipped it I don't think
it was as atrocious as some of the other
x-men movies could be and honestly I
expected it to not be that good
meta black International was a top tier
action filmmaker who just guided the
faster Furious franchise to I think
their biggest hit internationally a
billion-dollar hit with two of the top
stars working today with Tessa Thompson
and and Chris Hemsworth with all of that
might with no challenges in their way no
studio drama as far as getting sold no
no like reshoots no we had to reshoot
the third act to just pure talent and
they came up with nothing absolutely
nothing I think that's what makes it the
worst movie of this summer is absent
those huge challenges that that that
Dark Phoenix had they still were able to
came up with anything that's that's a
squandering of talent and it's a waste
of resources
it's joyless to sit through x-men at
least gave us that first ten minutes
which is a great x-men sequence at the
very least I can say like well Dark
Phoenix might not have been great but I
love that space sequence that's a great
one of them using their powers there's
something for me to cling on to not fit
them for me to cling onto a minibike
International Spider Man far from home
is a good movie the off screen politics
of it if next year or next week they
change this deal then the argument is
moot it doesn't change anything about
what's in the movie we're still gonna
get spider-man we're gonna get this
spider-man again it may not be tied to
the MCU but that doesn't change any
about what's in this movie and they're
free to explore what I think was the was
the cliffhanger of the film and the most
interesting thing about spider-man in
the next film anyway so I think it's a
stumbling block at best and may not even
be an issue at all
you know how I'm then looking around
this room and I look at my panel so look
at you I look at the gang on the castle
piers I look at the the thing and I say
we all have experienced heartbreak in
our life and so that that famous quote
from that author that's not Robert Frost
somebody else it's better to have loved
and lost than to not have loved at all I
think anybody's ever been through
heartbreak would disagree with that you
would rather not love at all then you
would have your heart ripped to pieces
now these two movies were talking about
are they the worst movies of the summer
or is it my panelists fault for walking
in with expectations and hoping that
they would be good we all walked into
spider-man and we walked out saying hey
we are excited about it and then you
know what happened our heart got broken
these movies were bad but spider-man's
the only one that broke our heart men
and blacks not good Dark Phoenix is not
good but spider-man's the only movie
that said you know what kids we hope you
enjoyed your time to Papa because he's
not coming home any ring-a-ding-ding
that's time all right
which one is the worst of the summer lon
you have some facts for us including who
that quote comes from Alfred Lord
Tennyson yeah his first name was Alfred
so Alfred comma Lord Tennyson was he a
lord or his lord his middle name he said
Lord like an English Lord oh it was a
50/50 shot between him and Sammy Hagar I
could not remember
oh you're confusing him with I can't
drive 55
Lord Tennyson I was gonna say like Ian
sir McKellen yeah sure is a night night
we title it's not it's not the same as
being a member of the revenge
thank you for your knowledge of British
royalty let's continue on so so many
pictures chief Tony Vince Agera said
today that quote for the moment the door
is closed on spider-man rejoin the MTU
but he added it's a long life so he's
leaving the doors on flight leave John
for the possibility of more spider-man
movies
druthers I'd rather throw backs ok
Douglas now we have to find out mark you
know what I see where you went and I
didn't follow you there not a lot of
people out there did either but the ones
that did the parties at Shakey's Pizza
Brian I am I for one agree with Alfred
Lord Tennyson it is better to have loved
and lost than to never have loved you're
in a happy productive relationship yeah
I just got married
yes so nobody should take your advice
true that is that has drawn many counts
but for this mark I appreciate the
creativity here here fight but it was it
was it was a fun movie it was a good
movie so it came down to me to Spencer
and Dan and you guys both had a lot of a
lot of moxie to what you were talking
about there you really believed that
these were joyless slobs and they both
were so it just came down to me who
painted the more joyless picture and
Spencer at the end you won me over with
the fact that the protagonist we didn't
know her yet she was posited as this
character that we were supposed to
really get on board with and it was in
just an intensely joyless bad movie I
liked just that like the the orphan
analogy I was disappointed with so much
from the director to the the lack of
chemistry with the cast and but yeah
Spencer got it from me lon where are you
[Music]
it was a noble effort but cutting in
your opening statement you said the
movie was just and we have two guys at
the table who are making very strong
cases for why their movies were terrible
which I think I like is worse than the
sound I mean I think the movies good my
heart I understand but so so I kind of I
kind of had to move beyond that so it
really came down to these two I thought
it was very close but yeah I agree with
how that Spencer really pulled it out
with a very strong argument there at the
end got a lot of reasons why the movie
didn't pay off sort of like underlying
reasons why it was a failure I'm going
with Spencer
alright um Danielle did you have any
thoughts on
my mate or thoughts would have been like
great great job great attempt great
really funny argument but yeah they
knocked him out super early - who were
you talking about
I couldn't gotcha see my love right
thank you and I just I wish I would have
heard a little bit more about specifics
about men and black it or not I could
not remember so yeah I would have agreed
to it was fun too as well right on Thank
You Danielle so Spencer you got that
point so it is Dan one Spencer when you
travel point houses we each have a point
it's one one mark looking to get on the
board thank you very much you're here
I'm here okay question number three here
we go we asked you which MC you phase
four movie will end up being the
breakout hit alright which MCU movie
will end up being just like lighting the
world on fire and we start with player
number three since it's question three
Dan yeah it's weird the MCU is kind of
going into the great unknown and so
there's a lot of unfrequented T's and
then some people that are getting movies
that we've we haven't seen a whole lot
of and so I went with the second Doctor
Strange movie which is coming out I
honestly think when I'm looking at it in
the multiverse of madness the the the
possibilities are unlimited and I think
coming off of endgame that concept
played so well the idea of when they
went back to the time heist and the idea
of all these splintering branches the
DES Loki show is kind of based off of
that but you know that's gonna be kind
of fresh in people's minds I think by
the time Doctor Strange comes out people
will have seen the Loki the low key idea
of things branching off and splintering
and also the the the limits of what the
movie can be I think are so wide and so
far-reaching I don't think it's just
gonna be Doctor Strange I think that
it's going to be Doctor Strange folding
in a lot of other characters which has
worked well for a lot of movies before
and I'll take that as my pick from the
unknown hit over the unknown quantities
because that's worked recently with
Captain Marvel and with Black Panther
but I think it's just as likely to not
work I think that when you're looking
for the one that's that got the
potential to be a breakout hit because
these are problem probably all gonna
make money let's be honest but the
breakout hit I'm gonna go with the
concepts that I believe has the most
possibilities that can fold in the most
characters interesting characters
characters from different time periods
of the MCU it's gonna be a different
tone they said it's gonna be more kind
of a horror film
I think it's be very unique very
different very interesting and I think
that could leave it to really break out
of the mold and build on what Doctor
Strange built in the first film alright
we'll hear more from you in a moment
mark which of these movie which movie
will be basically the old town road of
the MCU
I mean how all I heard and dance
argument is that he really wishes
spider-man could have been in the Doctor
Strange movie it's not gonna happen
again I'm sorry
alright the breakout a hit is going to
be shang-chi that is gonna be the movie
that is the biggest breakout hit of
phase 4 now you may be looking at me and
you say well mark what do you know about
shang-chi the answer is not a lot I do
not know a lot about chengjie the
property I did not read the comics nor
did I grow up being aware of this
character however how I will say this is
that if you're looking for a breakout
hit shang-chi checks all of the boxes
more so than any other film one of those
long stays for those boxes are inter
national box office appeal because they
character his daddy's Chinese and
Chinese dollars make big waves at the
box office if you can capitalize on that
market and guess what his mom get this
white woman women love going to the
movies when they're involved they're
gonna be involved in the making of
shang-chi and so not only do we get
China do we get the female demographic
we also you know where he has to go
confront somebody New York City
Manhattan we're getting the bigot that's
the greatest city in the world we're
gonna be tracking the globe with
Shanghai I just want to make sure I have
this right so that the boxes are
international Chinese appeal you know
what you get a sob rated washing mom
the fact that we are being involved in
this movie and so I think this has the
potential to be the biggest box office
head you didn't ask me what's gonna be
the best movie you didn't ask me yes
what is gonna be the best story you
asked me what is gonna be the breakout
hit and shang-chi the definite sort of
breakout here's a movie that we came out
of nowhere look at all the money it made
that is shang-chi 280 all right I'm
feeling that thank you Mark Spencer what
do you got yeah I'm afraid we're gonna
descend into the the multiverse of
semantics here because I picked mine
based on my definition of a breakout hit
which is that something you wouldn't
expect to do well thank you I would
expect a shang-chi for the reasons you
mentioned to you okay because mom's are
will always see a movie with another way
to do well but as little as Mark knows
about shang-chi I know even less about
the eternal I think um I think that I
have no idea what this film is about I
know that these are the godlike more
powerful beings in the MCU they are very
strong and large
don't have notes in front of me Spencer
has a notes in a pen dumb things you've
said these are not my notes I think this
do it don't bet against a barbell I
learned this lesson in phase two where
it guardians the galaxy's something else
I had not heard about but this was this
sounded so bizarre and so out there that
that's what people are the most curious
about and that's what people end up
seeing more than you'd expect them to is
like Wow an MCU movie that doesn't feel
like any of the other ones I've seen
origin stories I've seen the horrible
Iron Fist Netflix movie I've seen their
street-level kung-fu takes this is not a
white guy I'm just sorry you guys and
I've been opening it up and Doctor
Strange to like that's that's on a
breakout I think the expectations of dr.
strange too are already super high it's
gonna have Scarlet Witch in it and it
might not even do as well because
there's even rumors I believe that it
might be rated R is that true I don't
think there's anyone allow that to
happen I haven't read those rumors I I
can't imagine an MCU proper movie being
read but the horror genre if anything
could suppress its mass appeal to me
rather than like oh let's all take the
kids to see a horror movie it did
horribly which was rated R and yet still
made a bunch of money or does MCU to it
that's a horror movies didn't preclude a
huge audience a huge audience will show
up to see the right horror movie I think
that people will show up to see
something different
yeah like the Eternals who knows what
they are god like people like that's a
thing you're already confused by them no
I'm completely ignorant I'm in blissful
ignorance about them I think if people
liked about guardians of the galaxy at
the end of the day even though we looked
at it and we were like what is that was
that they were able to ground them
strangely and make them relatable yeah
and I don't know if you can do that with
the Turtles these godlike beings I don't
know if you can ground them enough that
the average person is gonna look at it
and say like oh I connected what'd they
do that I mean you get you'd think that
that's the way they're gonna go with
Angelina Jolie but she's pulled that off
in something like Maleficent where she
is this otherworldly evil force but then
it turns out oh she wanted to kidnap a
princess from make her her daughter I
it's been a long time
very relatable feeling great relatable
feeling but I think that's really
struggle with Captain Marvel Captain
Marvel is their most powerful character
I think thus far introduced and I think
that's where the movie struggled was
relating to her and finding a way to get
the audience to relate to her because
she's so powerful because there wasn't
anyone for her to bounce off against the
Eternals as I recall is plural so that
means there's more than one of them
there's more than one eternal they're
going to face off they're going to have
friends but here's the thing bunch of
guys it's a bunch of God the reason why
guardians of the galaxy was such a
breakout hit is because that movie had
some funny in it it had a lot of humor
and it had a talking raccoon now there's
no talking raccoons that are gonna be in
Turtles and less food unless rocket
shows up in eternals which is still not
gonna do what guardians of the galaxy
did and as far as the Doctor Strange
movie goes I do agree with Spencer's
point that this is Scott Derrickson said
he wants this to be a horror movie if it
is rated R it could do well it could do
boffo box-office but it does not have
the same appeal as another horror film
like it does internationally it did very
well but this is not it this is
something totally different this in the
terms of the MCU is gonna be what is the
International what does the thing is
going to take over the globe and the
fact that we have a superhero that is of
a nationality we've never seen
represented in this way in the MCU
is going to be the biggest boon for this
thing not only doing well in the United
States as we know all MC movies are
gonna do this is going to have
international appeal far and beyond
eternal I don't know if people are gonna
see eternal Z on Jupiter or in Mars okay
but I know that people on earth care
about shang-chi and they care about it
all over all MCU movies do great in
China like that's nonsense that's not a
shocking thing it's gonna do matter when
you get to see yourself on screen for
the first time we've seen evidence of
that if you have a female superhero that
is leading movie if you have somebody
like Black Panther who is leading a
movie and finally a huge demographic can
go see hey that could be me up there
that's what shang-chi is going to do
that
dr. strange has there's a lot of white
guys who wear capes already but there's
a lot of people from outer space already
I wouldn't I wouldn't send that everyone
in China is gonna go see the movie cuz
there's a Chinese person in it because
there are a lot of Chinese action movies
that already come out in China
starring Chinese people it's not a
novelty that somebody made it there's
more movies but that should I into the
biggest franchise on earth those action
movies I'm not in China cuz it has a
Chinese lead there's a lot of really
good Chinese in Hong Kong action movies
that come out in China every year way
more than come out here but they don't
have the budgets that the mouse does
they do in China makes action movies now
domestically on their own that have
bigger budgets and are bigger spectacles
then then shang-chi is going to Nancy
Matt Damon's the wall there's Chinese
project companies that have more money
to spend than Disney yes yeah well for
year 2 is a bigger spectacle as a
massive hit in China an action movie
that came out in China that is that it
has a bigger probably spectacle than
Shane she is gonna have but as far as
putting budget and putting an
international promotion thing because
again I said it's going to do well in
China not just China though this is
gonna be something all over the globe
where again I think that your movie
primarily I'm not very excited to say I
think it's gonna do its best business in
the United States and I think the
Eternals is gonna do
I just don't know know who knows that's
why it would be a breakout I think we're
losing perspective here of the the
potential and the possibility of these
films because you know the least about
your of course Dan once you hit us with
some final thoughts yeah absolutely guys
the most likely to just plunge through
the bottom it has a very low floor if it
does well breakout hit breakout hits
it's like oh I guess it's it ok a
breakout hit I think is something that
makes people stand up and go wow
for example thor ragnarok to me was a
breakout hit not only because it did a
lot of money but because people looked
at the character in a new way
recontextualized it was something
different and new and people really
completely change their idea of what
Thor was of what that franchise was
based on that movie I think that was a
breakout hit in a genre where all of
their movies make a bunch of money as
Shane she does well in China again
Marvel movies do well in China I don't
think it's gonna be as big a deal with
China as it is here because like I said
a Chinese action stars exist in China
already and and there are a lot of great
Chinese action movies that get made I
don't think it's theirs it's a draw just
because it stars somebody from China I
love that there is representation from
that demographic in the MCU I think
that's a great point but I don't think
that's necessarily like oh it's gonna be
a breakout hit I think it's also just as
likely that it's gonna be kind of
generic I mean you've got the Mandarin
the ten rings the Mandarin is a villain
that you're gonna have to retcon that
people are another organised story you
know you have to figure out like this is
like their third Mandarin potentially
they're trying to kind of haphazardly
clumsily tie it into Iron Man I think
you can go wrong there Doctor Strange
and the multiverse of madness I think
allows infinite possibilities and like
Thor Ragnarok did can completely
recontextualize how people think of that
character and that's what I define as a
breakout hit something that makes people
go like oh you know the first movie was
okay but that movie really makes me
excited about the future of this
character and they really did something
fun and special and unique and that's
why I picked them thank you dan Moreau
Marc sure breakout ahead expectations
and something we're already aware of but
I don't see that potential with Doctor
Strange I see Doctor Strange maybe going
are maybe going a darker route is going
to handcuff it more for an international
or for even a national audience that is
just in the United States wanting to go
see that movie with the Eternals eye
that that reeks of like oh we're trying
too hard to either be guardians of the
galaxy which audiences are smart they'll
sniff it out or just reeks of like a
Fantastic Four hey we try to do another
comic book and it didn't work out so
let's get rid of this thing real quick
with shang-chi you have the ability like
what Wonder Woman did when you have a
giant demographic of people never got to
see themself on screen before in that
way same thing with Black Panther they
never got to see themselves on screen
that way before yes there's been plenty
of movies that have Asian leads that are
kick-ass action movies none of them have
occurred in the biggest franchise on
earth right now that is the MCU I know
there's a lot of movies that do well in
China that we never hear about here the
United States shang-chi is going to be
the one that unites all of them
together and I think the fact that the
Mandarin is the villain in this movie
which I just got that update is that we
finally get to see there's so many fans
who wanted to see the Mandarin done
right done justice and now we have the
chance to do that so that's gonna get
even more people into the theater this
is the breakout hit this is what's gonna
surprise people you didn't know Shane
she was before you're gonna know who is
afterwards thank you Mark Ellis
I just spent I think the other two or
gimmies I think if all of these all of
these films all made say a billion
dollars shang-chi debuts - a billion
dollars oh yeah of course China showed
up in and across that line Doctor
Strange - yeah okay I can say that
making building hours the Eternals what
is the Eternals how did that movie make
a billion dollars it's the breakout hit
of face Thank You Spencer
ring-a-ding-ding the definition of
breakout being or relating to a sudden
or smashing success
especially in comparison to previous
efforts just wanted to get that out
there a lot of the debate set around it
which I thought oh come more fact dr.
strange - very likely to be pg-13
despite having a harm and be toned
that's what we're hearing from around
the web I have to say the Eternals
human-looking
AV Club says they're very not giants
suggested and finally despite everything
that was saying mostly about you know
there are big Chinese huge spectacle
action movies they make a ton of money
they're very popular they do star
Chinese actors they do tend to have
budgets that are a lot lower than their
American counterparts wolf warrior - had
a budget of about 30 million wandering
earth had a budget of about 50 million
dr. Marvel was a hundred and fifty two
million dollar budget for compared but
if you adjust for inflation when Dan was
going to high school in 1907 13
back then when they said druthers lon
what are your thoughts on it so
interested so around I feel like Spencer
it was a little thin it was mostly like
I don't know what the Eternals are so he
needed that picture hold the image at
them
the semantics around the word break out
too much so I didn't really think of
that word mark had a really good
argument in terms of representation this
movie's going to go to China it's gonna
be excited for Chinese audience as a
Chinese guy in the MCU but I wanted to
hear more I feel like we kept returning
to the representation argument over and
over again I feel like that will
contribute to its success but I felt
like Dan had so many good arguments for
why Doctor Strange 2 is gonna be a huge
success in resonate with audiences I got
to go with it ok that's one for Dan I
saw it a little bit differently I agree
with you on Spencer you know you had
some good general thoughts about the
film but there weren't enough specifics
as to why it would pop so yeah I gotta
put you in third place in this argument
right here so between Dan and Marc I
thought Dan had a lot of strong
specifics about why it might be a good
film and why I want to see it like I'm
interested in seeing the multi-verse and
Scarlet Witch and how she's gonna factor
in and a time heist but the most
powerful argument came from Marc in
regards to the international box office
the representation on screen and Dan I
feel like it just didn't quite hold
water saying that the the a Marvel
character who was Chinese being big in
China that is going to be huge I was
actually in Japan when Avengers end game
came out and it was insanity and for a
Marvel film to have a Chinese lead
opening in Asia I mean it's going to do
gangbusters business and the the seeing
and the representation like in black
panther and crazier rotations and like
seeing yourself on screen is a huge deal
so I think that could overwhelm the box
office in favor of shang-chi so it's one
one
let's go Danielle radford yeah it's me
so I just felt like Spencer got crowded
out and it wound up being a lot of them
kind of going back and forth with each
other this is a
because these were both fantastic
arguments the representation argument is
huge lord knows black panther got all of
our black dollars we were happy to give
it to them several times but this is one
thing where I you make a fatal mistake
when you bring a box office fight to Dan
I think the point of not necessarily
always working in your favor so while I
do think that that was a fantastic
argument because Dan had more arguments
than because I felt like that was kind
of the one that yours hinged on he was
also able to counter that with genuine
like knowledge and facts because box
office is kind of his thing so I got to
get back to Dan Oh Marc you just got
sharted box office crazier JC's did not
do well in China they dig a lot of the
Chinese audience found it to be very
because if it wasn't in the MCU crazy
rotation some how can you get woven into
the fabric of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe now sky's the limit for that
sequel oh we're looking at a crossover
they're so going to question for is Dan
to Spencer one mark god got one mm no
get on the board we don't have a
scoreboard right in front of us no I
assumed I had a plots no there's a
scoreboard right there London oh yeah
there's a scoreboard right right on the
screen there all right question number
think it says I have eight but question
number four so we asked which streaming
service is the least likely to exceed
which streaming service least likely to
succeed and come around mark start us
off now look you might have seen my
previous arguments today and you said
full mark you're just you're just
throwing stuff against the wall you
don't really feel that way about
spider-man far from home you know
nothing about Schanke wait until you see
this argument because I have evidence on
my cellular telephone oh I have multiple
emails from a service called fubo TV
that sounds cool now what food TV is is
they claim that they will bring you live
sports as they're happening
and so three beers deep Mark Ellis last
Thanksgiving decided I'm gonna sign up
for this Peugeot TV and I'm gonna watch
me the Washington Dallas game and I'm
gonna press the whole family by hooking
it up because for some godforsaken
reason my brother who is in Seattle
which could get a DirecTV dish does not
have cable so I hookup fubo TV and I
sign up for it how I cannot get out of
this goddamn contract to save my life I
keep getting emails about who I need to
call and who I should go if anybody
knows how they I just want to cancel
fubo TV they've ruined my credit I can't
get an apartment in this town anymore
I'm sleeping in the back of the Laugh
Factory
because FUBU TV has robbed me not only
of my soul it has robbed my eyeballs of
anything good to watch and it has robbed
my bank account of all credibility when
it comes to mr. taxman I'm not paid my
taxes in a year because of fubo TV now
the other thing fubo TV doesn't have is
any of the good shows that you're gonna
hear from Spencer dance streaming
service fubo TV they don't have any of
the they don't have the mandalorian fumo
TV is not gonna have Netflix comedy
specials fubo TV is not gonna have star
trek into discovery they're not gonna
have the other Star Trek show darkness
falls they're not gonna have the card
there are you kidding me is the Eternals
of the streaming service world in the
sense that we don't know well it is
watch Dave Chappelle sticks and stones
on football you can see absolutely
nothing on fubo TV no it was a 10-minute
delay and so I had to log into my NFL
DirecTV game I still got to see on 10
minutes off have you ever tried to watch
a live sport ten minutes after the fact
it is atrocious how you may as well not
be watching sports at all may as well go
back to knitting or playing with your
dolls in your bathtub whatever you grown
people do if you're not watching
athletic marquel has got burned by FUBU
all right Spencer uh if I recall I
picked is it Apple Plus yes yeah Apple
Plus man that thing's gonna be a year
and then Apple plus Apple TV plus is the
luxury boutique premium subscription
service from Apple with all sorts of
shows from all sorts of people that
you've never seen and never will because
Apple is going to get bored of this and
cancel it in a year
there is no library on which to build on
and as we found as Netflix is
discovering to its dismay people go on
streaming services to watch friends and
the office and they have no friends and
they have no office of which to speak of
this is all banking on launching all
these original properties from all these
people it's not very clear how many
episodes what it's going to be it's
expensive you don't know how much
content there's gonna be at the end I
watched that whole presentation of like
Jason Momoa love the guy he's like it's
a show get ready no hype and then
furthermore on top of that Apple is what
a almost a trillion dollar company this
is not their bread and butter they do
not make their money this way they have
no skin in the game so to speak there's
no reason for them to try to make this
work unlike a Disney or Netflix who
needs this to succeed they'll try it
just to throw their hat in the ring suit
it's not making money and cancel it
Thank You Spencer dan what do you got I
am going with nbc/universal max whatever
the eventual streaming service from that
sounds like a fact check for long they
are trying to position themselves as
being in the game with the Hulu with
Warner boxes and the Disney pluses of
the world and this is what they have
proposed thus far yes
paying hundreds of millions of dollars
for exclusive rights to a show the
office that you can buy on Amazon as
well and watch as much as you want or
less than it costs to subscribe to a
year of their service
by the way it will probably have
commercial breaks in it so they're
literally pitching the old way that
people hated watching television so much
that they abandoned it the second that
TiVo came by so you're starting at
negative hundreds of millions of dollars
for a show that anyone can just buy and
watch it their own convenience
commercial free anytime that they want
and that's literally their only plan
right now they're staking everything on
one show almost anywhere else ever
cheaper I feel like we're not even
having an argument like Ana's show I
feel like Dan cornered Spencer tonight
do they all they also have friends yeah
you might as well call this trapped at a
table with Dan yes they also they may
also by friends for hundreds of million
alonso they know HBO warner so hundreds
of millions of dollars for a show that
you can buy other in other places
potentially probably without commercials
and that's it's so far Apple Plus at
least has number one a lot of talent
attached to make shows you got JJ Abrams
you got Steven Spielberg yes they're
unknown quantities but they could be
fantastic and number two it's got Apple
in the name
have you seen Apple France fans I could
take a [ __ ] in a box and call it AI dump
and they were outside the Apple store
doorman yeah the the glitz and the glam
is gone that is a hardcore base of
people that will buy anything that says
Apple blank in front of it where I blink
it's shrinking but the eye dump is an
underrated product only at the Genius
Bar so you see your I dump doesn't work
okay we're gonna need some burritos and
Kubo to me sounds like the perfect
product they don't have to pay to make
anything and once you sign up for it you
can't believe I still CBS all access for
three years because I can't be bothered
to click two buttons on my ryote
subscribe I sign up at the time trial
every year to watch the Superbowl but
one stand of things that work on
streaming our library content stuff that
exists stuff the people can just
marathon that they know will always be
there for them which NBC even if they
don't have friends they have so many
shows from their history if they can
pull 30 rock if they can get a Frasier
Seinfeld they can also pull and be a
dick move but if they really want this
to work they can pull it from Amazon no
you can't buy friends off Amazon the
only place you can get it now is on NBC
comm whatever Universal Plus fubo the
other thing people still watch TV for
sports I'm told people who watch sports
right and you have to pay to watch it
there's no free way of getting sports
and it sounds like once you're in you
can't get out that you pay for and can't
get out of like that that may not be a
good business practice but they're gonna
be successful
look how here's the thing okay I'm gonna
give you what what Spencer said about
Dan's thing and what Dan said about
Spencer's thing I'm gonna give you that
again just after the fact a lot like
what fubo TV does in sports is that
after the event is done or when you
already know what happened when you
already got the update the one thing I'm
listening to arguments about how to
watch live sports from people who do not
watch a lot of live sports like sports
then you because you didn't give me that
argument Spencer did Spencer basically
say well they give you sports you do
sports 10 minutes after it happened is
literally worthless it does not matter I
they already have that and you can just
watch SportsCenter after the fact I
can't tell you why I can't tell you why
in my soul and everything
so much money off conning your friends
just show them the fubo side up see on
Twitter tell your friends that fubo is
ten minutes behind and you sneak if
you're feeling like I'll bet your ties
emails over the first movie email
welcome to the team get started they're
70 channels including Discovery Nick jr.
and Nickelodeon that's their lead sled
dog howl Nick jr. lead Nick jr. leading
the charge what do you wanna do are you
trying to get me arrested if you get
food Oh TV you get to go door-to-door
sources tell me it's a better deal and
then I got another email from fubo your
account needs attention I just wanted to
end FUBU now look how to be to be fair
here Apple and NBC they both have a lot
of money to put into a streaming service
the only money and fubo has is mine mark
let's make this your final thoughts go
ahead and is there anything else you
want to add I would like that a lot of
things yes is that the bottom line is
that nobody's ever heard of FUBU TV and
the question is what is the least likely
to succeed it's gonna be a streaming
service then nobody's ever heard of
nobody knows what fubo TV is everybody
knows Apple everybody knows NBC NBC has
a lot of built-in brands like we love
our office we love other things that NBC
can produce and Apple has a lot of
original content that they've announced
with big-name stars and directors Bubo
TV has none of that
it just has sports that is done the
sport has ended and then you get to
watch it on fubo what a bargain give me
my money back
Wow sounds more like fubar TV mark am i
right all right Spencer
I don't know spending like a cheaper
cable package that just gives you all
the sports channels sounds like a pretty
good deal and I'm glad I'm better giving
them the Free Press because now fubar TV
will get that boost and
I gave them my Gmail usually just give a
streaming service my hotmail I gave them
my so clearly it was a good enough
proposition that you signed up and paid
real hard earned money for Apple and a
coil Apple just you know it's not just
the money it's the will they have no
will they do not want to get it in the
original content they have no no spine
they they can't they're not there to
stick it out they are a company that is
designed to sell the next iPhone and the
next I whatever the next iPod they do
not know what they're doing they're just
thrown a little cash this way and seeing
what happens that is not the makings of
a long-term business Thank You Spencer
damn Apple is one of the ones that's put
their money where their mouth is I would
say they have no spine there they're
attracting more top-level Talent
collectively than any of the other
streaming service I think that's worth
something I think the reason that
everyone's down on them right now a
little bit is that we haven't really
seen any of what they're making and I
understand that it's the great unknown
but at the same time I think there's a
lot of potential Plus Apple has
something that nobody else has which is
the ability to send their programming
directly to their consumers on the
devices that they're spending hours a
day on already their iPhones yeah when
they gave everyone YouTube we all loved
it everything everybody in the game sold
for free and at one u2 u2 album versus
being able to start on the episode and
have a base of millions of people that
you can send that episode to and say you
can watch this for free that's an
advantage that no other service has and
that Apple does have whereas NBC
Universal is part of a dinosaur of a
dying cable dynasty nobody wants to give
the old guard their money as far as like
Oh Comcast NBC no I think the Comcast
people I like I just I just I just quit
I just I just left them behind them
that's I'm just gonna buy the office for
80 bucks on Amazon with no commercials
and watch it there there's an easy
alternative to NBC Universal streaming
service thus far why bother why bother
to make that big of a spend for
something that may not even work out
with the office I don't understand it
there's better ways to watch the one
thing they're building their entire
platform around it is a one-trick pony
it's gonna fail fubo i hear about a new
thing that's been out for like 15 years
so like oh you never heard of smash
smash it's been around for 12
these little ones are the ones that are
gonna be around move oh is no mishmash
oh it's gonna be I wouldn't be shocked
if at the end all of the companies that
put hundreds of billions of dollars fold
and fubo is there to pick up they
survive I'm just Oh God food I'm alright
Ilan what are we got in the back zone
this is over 250,000 users today I think
like a hundred of them are intentionally
on Thanksgiving is the rule pull in
content from some pretty big child AMC
FX Bravo Fox News TBS USA Network's
sci-fi Sundays degree empty the IFC all
have content on Freebo only other fact
that I found the Seinfeld streaming
rights will become available in 2021
they're expected to set up a pretty big
bidding war netflix says they want it
and are prepared to spend half a billion
dollars you know who else wants it you
know you want some possibility for a
Comcast to pick up for NBC you could
also go to Netflix or anywhere else who
knows Conchas does say they're planning
to spend a lot of money to license shows
for this NBC you service gotcha
thank you on Danielle please chime in
with your thoughts on this question oh
man this is so all of these sound
terrible you did a great job with making
I want to spend money with any of these
services congratulations the Apple plus
one got ding which with the arguments
about all the creators that they're
bringing in and the fact that the Union
doesn't really need it to work so that
one was taken out for me so it was
between nbc/universal and Fuu and fubo
TV and I've got it you know I get markup
on let's almost get him up on the board
because for this one specifically
because you know people will just go cuz
you had the argument that you know
people are just gonna watch you know the
things that they already watch and I
think that Spencer did a great job of
saying like yeah like that's why people
were watching things on Netflix and I
feel like with fubo weirdly I didn't
feel like I got hammered so you can make
good mark on this one that's one for
mark long with you I was prepared no it
was it was damn close but I got the eye
I just got the the impression that fubo
would be the it's like kind of the
little engine that could of these of
these net like and they make it so hard
to get out of there con just thrown all
my calls as a vengeance yeah so uh
people are gonna enter coupon code movie
fights for a 20 percent discount
yeah are gonna be locked in and not not
able to get out Spencer I thought you
put all a lot of your argument into like
oh you know apples gonna try and then
they'll get bored with it like we don't
know that and then there are some strong
creators
I thought dan had the best argument as
far as the lack of content and then go
sending my money back to Comcast Comcast
after I thought I'd cut the cord so yeah
I thought the most compelling argument
that the most passion came from Marc but
the most compelling argument came from
Dan for me so it's one one one who do
you got yeah
mark vs Dan for me on this one I just
thought like you know Apple TV maybe
right that they're not gonna really try
that hard but there's so much money to
throw around
I feel like Apple might luck out and
stick around for a few just based on if
they get one or two shows that connect a
few years mark came at it from me it's
not a well-run company it's disorganized
chaotic it thinks things don't work the
way you want there to but I felt like
ultimately other Dan had the strongest
case where it was there just there's not
only do they not have the content ready
to go but they don't really have any way
to get the content and it's going to be
with ads which is what people left the
old cable version to get away from I'm
gonna pin alright Dan you take the point
and you move into a 3-1 lead so I have
to mention this because I just looked it
up yes it's $55 a month what are you
[Music]
swimming in debt my wife my kids don't
even want to talk to me because daddy
can't give them a good Christmas watch
some live sports might get some of the
dirty channels for all that cash all
right
oh my god all right here it is Hobbs and
Shah came out true story so we ask you
we're gonna ask you to know it did we're
gonna ask you to pick two names out of
this hat and pitch their team up movie
and you'll pick random names and that we
will and will that we secretly put in
this hat before the show all right go
ahead and pick two all right and start
thinking about your team up immediately
got one and got the rather good Spenny
Danny Spencer you're gonna be going
first so think for a moment and I want
you to just first let's hear who you got
Spencer all right I got a Will Smith's
character Mike Lowrey from bad boys it's
paired with Bruce Willis as himself a
bad boy and a bad man dan I got Deena
from girls trip which is Tiffany Haddish
is character and Bo Peep from story okay
okay that's gonna be a common
misadventure yeah and Mark Ellis
I got Saul Guerrero from rogue one sure
and Derek Zoolander okay great Spencer
why don't you want you into that pitch
everyone's real worried about the
diehard prequel right McClane is that
what it's gonna be called John McClane
this is either that movie or a meta film
to come out before that movie so the
studio's worried about the die-hard
prequel they can tell that Bruce Willis
has been phoning it in for about seven
films now and they are in an attempt to
reignite his interest in police work
they're having him Shadow the hottest
funnest most engaged detective a cop in
this in Miami Mike Lowrey from bad boys
so it is a ride-along situation where
Bruce Willis is a jaded actor who thinks
he knows it all and is over it over it
and doesn't even care about this movies
just doing it for a paycheck he is
paired with the the woo man himself Will
Smith and they actually go on a drug
bust you know a Miami they uncover a
Miami Beach cocaine dealer that goes all
the way back to the movie studio that
there whoa oh my god Bruce Willis is
finally engaged he finally falls back in
love with acting back in love with
police work and he makes a great pretty
cool to die hard yet all right that was
great except I thought the Wu man was
Ric Flair thank you damn Oh girls trip
we all remember oh yeah great film I'm
in quad fun peeing on the crowd yeah - I
believe as as deserving of an Oscar
nominations for that film as most of
Karthi was for bridesmaids second and I
think that was my by far my favorite
performance suffers a breakout
performance so we bring her back for the
sequel but it's an all new ladies trip
and who better to join the gang then Bo
Peep we Bo Peep has found herself Bo
Peep has found herself as of late as we
saw in Toy Story 4 she's found her
independence she's she's gonna leave
woody at the carnival and she's hitting
the road baby with the Deena from girls
trip and the gang all the rest of them
was cut from the first of all
in this movie redemption for Nick and
girls and it's just gonna be it's just
gonna be fun it's just gonna be fun
girls trip but with a lamp a girls trip
to you with Bo Peep and Tim hash mark
pickups my man how like my chances of
winning today my chair is sinking you
know I could just do this all right look
this is gonna be a married you
rollicking comedy 48 hours Beverly Hills
Cop where you have a mismatched pair and
that against Sagar arrow from rogue one
is he represents when you see him in the
movie a guy who has just been through
the worst that a person can go through
he he's got that faraway stare at his
eyes that ten-mile distance he's so
jaded he's got all of the distaste of
modern society that a war veteran might
and the reason why he has that because
he signed up for fubo TV to find the
headquarters of fubo TV which is very
tough and he finally tracks them down in
the country of Luxembourg where fubo TVs
headquarters aren't when he gets there
who does he run into but beleaguered
down-on-his-luck model Derek Zoolander
who can only get some hand modeling work
in the country of luxembourg and once
Derek tells him that he had a contract
with Bubo TV for some foot modeling that
went awry saw teams up with Derek and
maybe they just given up zany looks and
enough gritty gutty laser blasters to
get inside the headquarters of FUBU TV
and rescue sauger eras bank account once
and for all
alright y'all want to poke some holes
listen as they both pitch the same
dynamic we've seen a million times a
grumpy grumpy gruff dude and like
charismatic other guy like that it works
for a reason he ever made but yeah I
want you know what I've never seen a
roadtrip comedy with a lamp never seen
it in my life yep yes
right I haven't seen is that accurate
stammers yeah we get an teapots more
work which is always a good thing
anything that gets any pots more work
now is this animated mix like you Framed
Roger Rabbit oh it's a rabbit so you
have live-action Tiffany Haddish cg bo
peep from Toy Story for not the size of
Tiffany Haddish lamp size because and
just imagine the visuals of her buckled
into the front seat of the car this tiny
little porcelain lamp you're taking away
her greatest strength which is riffing
it up I don't think you can do improv
with an animated character because it
takes like years of rendering and you
need to pre write she needs to be
looking in the right place you can't let
TIFF riff you should know do you see Jon
Favreau it made Lion King with like in
real times like virtual reality goggles
James Cameron is directing this so the
technological innovation of this yeah
this is gonna be his follow-up to Avatar
2 he's scrapping the rest and he's
making Tiffany Haddish Bo Peep because
he wants to be the first director to
make a lamp mixture he wants to be the
first director to make a mixture of
live-action CGI lamp road trip Lord and
Miller to write and direct they can do
meadow with 21 Jump Street real well and
I just love the character dynamics not
just like Oh one's jaded and one is uh
is still like too in love with his job
because that's that's given a fresh coat
of paint because that's the truth of
Bruce Willis and Will Smith Will Smith
still cares Will Smith still shows up
and gives 110 percent and Bruce Willis
has abandoned acting for you know the
veil of Tears since 1992 Marc who's
directing yours well it was again of the
Lord and Miller and they're available to
do Spencer's project because we brought
in Ron Howard to replace them
this one with Derrick and the charm of
my movie how is that belong together and
they're in such a preposterous ly funny
situation they look so lead to some real
life lessons where I feel like Bruce
Willis well past his prime people don't
want to see Will Smith team with Bruce
Willis they're excited about bad boys
for life for a reason because it's him
back with Martin Lawrence they don't see
Will Smith team up with Bruce Willis and
with dance movie I think that that's not
for either audience because I don't
think that parents want their kids to go
see Bo Peep in a movie with sort of a
foul-mouthed comedian and I don't think
the Tiffany Haddish fans want to see
Tiffany house his comedy watered down hi
I think we've heard more all right
great pitches great pitches from
everybody not everybody Dan you came in
hard with those with that that imagery
at the end was James Cameron the live
action that almost took it for me
but at the end of the day someone just
had an unbeatable pitch right out of the
gate and to me
it was Spencer with the real Bruce
Willis going in with a fictional cop
with this meta relationship based on the
gruff Willis demeanor him trying to get
in the zone for the McClane movie with
the bad boys and then the drug plot goes
back to the studio
see I just recited the whole thing
because I love it I'm controlling its
Greenland you you're greenlit from me
Spencer that's one for Spencer lon who
do you got oh yeah sorry sorry it is
called MacLean well done fubo TV
headquartered in New York but I love the
setting of Luxembourg so much I say we
know it wants you to think of throwing
this out to the group yeah does the file
of Galadriel from Lord of the Rings
count as a lamp being brought on a road
trip in life that was the lightless star
there was not a limp thank you thank you
comic book man
alright so who do you I mean I really
did think everybody made some really
exciting fun pages out yeah not a lot to
go on
I do agree that dance felt to me the the
thinnest it just basically felt like the
first movie but also there's this laugh
as brilliant as Spencer's original
content like when he first pitched that
I was like that sounds like a movie he's
gonna win but Marcus added some details
that appeal to it I think the craziness
of the scenario of these two guys
bringing down all right reading issue
International dollars from Luxembourg
[Laughter]
okay so it's one one Danielle make some
sense of this please how could I sure an
impossible task just a valiant effort no
I don't think it was again it was
between mark and Spenny for me and while
Spencer's is the one that actually does
sound like a movie that could be made I
did like the how Mark continued to add
on and add on and add on something with
mark
or means we are all tied up to see who's
going to go into the speed round here is
the tiebreaker the tiebreaker between
Spencer and mark works thusly I will ask
the question shout out your answers then
you have 20 seconds to elaborate on your
answer and then we'll get ten-second
rebuttals after that in the order that
you answer the best man enjoy luck
sports
$55 a month no cancellation policy for
who we do want to move on who you want
to all right there is a you know you
know as usual I only read what's in
front of me there is no tie great
question in front of me so I am going to
make one
[Music]
question yes all right here it is best
Sylvester Stallone movie rocky 4 oh
great rocky rocky all right we have
rocky 4 I heard rocky 4 first and then
rocky so Marc you will go first you have
20 seconds on the clock Spencer you will
go second rocky 4 has everything you
want it's a great film a documentary
rocky 4 literally ended the Cold War and
it was the precursor to the Berlin Wall
falling because it taught us that
communism is not the answer what is the
answer getting in the ring one more time
defending your best friend who has
fallen at the hands of the evil Yvonne
Drago and you know what maybe even if on
Drago learned a little something because
if I can change and you can change
everybody can change rocky Ford didn't
in the Cold War the Cold War ended the
Cold War the USSR is it was built on a
house of sand that's a different story
Rocky is a Best Picture winner this is a
true personal story from Sylvester
Stallone the greatest performance he's
ever given and probably ever will
because it was so intensely personal and
is the ultimate underdog story there's a
reason why Rocky is the analogy that
gets thrown around to every other time
rocky won a lot of awards but it does
not mean that it stands the test of time
like rocky 4 does rocky 4 airs endlessly
more than rocky rocky takes 38
commercial breaks before he gets
interesting rocky 4 interesting right
out of the gate everything you love
about rocky 4 is just a heightened
version of what's in rocky and playing
it more realistic playing as a
hardscrabble philadelphia story works
the first time it doesn't work as well
the second third fourth fifth sixth
seventh and eighth time this time okay
so you know what you would have thought
the Academy Award would have taken it
but he dinged you you didn't really ding
and he painted the more compelling
picture of the movie so while my brain
says Spencer hmm based on the
information I'm going to mark Danielle
um I gotta go the opposite both really
great arguments but I thought that
particularly the that last bit when you
mentioned that it works well the first
time but it doesn't continue to work
afterwards all right delay on horse
racing and then they place the bet if I
could have won one debate here today I'm
glad that it was Hager Aaron Derek's
taking down if I could vote for two
people to take down fubo it's gonna be
those go alright fubo your your your
headquarters is burning as we speak well
fought my friend you guys still validate
right uh do I just hang out you know
what we'll bring into the fun yeah you
sounded like that's not something you
normally do but
it's not well because but you're such an
esteemed guest of course
cart blonde mark yeah you got my vote
you can Alonzo a round here we go so uh
Spencer Spencer won the tiebreak but
that did not count for a point so we
enter at three one it is game point okay
so it's two five yes yeah well now from
now on it's yeah I've got a
mathematically one yeah gotcha so it's
it's three two one first player to five
correct yes here we go three one Dan
first player to five here is the
question
same rules as the tiebreak I'll ask the
questions out out your answer than the
20 seconds 20 seconds then ten second
rebuttals Stuber was great huh sorry
that was the question so we asked what
comedian wrestler duo should do an
action movie next comedian wrestler okay
comedian slash and right-hander wrestler
or comedian wrestler duo I think the
word I think the word duo Clark yeah
you're right you're right you're right
Jeff see I wrote this one but you pick a
comedian courses it he wrote about
coming in wrestling
you know what I'll call inaudible you
can pick an MMA guy if you want yeah
yeah you wish you had that FUBU
subscription now don't you
so wrestler or MMA guy no it's the
comedian hard to find me but yeah go
ahead go ahead
Oh coke and Dave Chappelle okay fine I'm
sort of playing fast and loose in the
definition of comedian I'm doing a Stone
Cold Steve Austin and Kevin Sorbo
okay stone cold and Kevin Hart there we
go
we heard Dan first 20 seconds begin when
you speak yeah I want to see the suit
paired up just to see them argue about
like what things they aren't allowed to
say who's a mutually hate and don't hate
where do they overlap just thinking the
fascination where their biases intersect
where their hatred of like the media
differs and doesn't their where their
thoughts on just like society like got
my god that sounds like an extremely
uncomfortable experience I know that
Kevin Hart despite what he does outside
of his films keeps things light keeps
things fun and fresh and stone cold is
like the gruff you know old cantankerous
man and and he's really good with Kevin
Hart's great physical comedy I want to
see Kevin Hart get stone-cold stunned I
believe that's a wrestling Lube so I win
we've done the funny guy teams up with
the wrestling thing and then before
that's the whole wrestling formula it's
tiled cinema is uncomfortable sometimes
that I won't see this going in history
through these two people it's gonna be a
train wreck but what a glorious train
wreck cinema can be uncomfortable but
you don't want your comedy to be
uncomfortable you want to be laughing
not cringing and I think that Kevin Hart
will at least give you a few big laughs
big voices big physical action comedy
beets and stone cold can't keep up time
all right good work fellas
you know why we're gonna give the first
stuff out here too
mark tell the kids tables up I don't
want an official vote I just suck you
know I don't get my quick there is no
problem with you having a vote on this
ridiculous dog and pony show I would see
I would go see either movie I think the
Kevin Hart and stone cold is a good team
up but I think that if you're looking at
trying to create a buzz create a stir I
think that Hulk Hogan and Dave Chappelle
succeeds in that a little bit more
because Spencer had a good point where
he went against Dan and he said that hey
well this could make some people
uncomfortable and so I'm gonna borrow
Spencer's own argument against him from
Eternals is that yes this Hulk Hogan
Dave Chappelle has a much lower ceiling
know as a much lower floor higher floor
weight you're going down that's one for
Dan Danielle Wow this is interesting
I'm assuming that this this Hong Kong
good and Dave Chappelle thing is a
documentary like it's a comedic ducky
yeah kind of like coffee and cigarettes
or something like that yeah
man I know exactly what kind of movie
the Kevin Hart and Stone Cold Steve
Austin movies gonna be you hit
everything it's gonna be it's gonna be
light so he's gonna get stone-cold
stunned it's gonna be a lot of laughing
and not cringing does Dave Chappelle and
in Hulk Hogan movie where they are just
two people who probably hate each other
visibly in a car together that's that is
some buzz worthy stuff so all right Dan
you get that point it is for one game
point Oh disaster yeah Kevin Hart get
well soon I don't want to see him get
stone-cold stun oh yeah yeah all right
question number two at his game point
for Dan what summer 2019 movie would you
fix by replacing the lead with Nicolas
Cage what summer 2019 movie would you
Godzilla king of the monsters okay
Godzilla Godzilla with
okay and is it okay we'll hear more
replacing Godzilla with Nikolas I think
we need more yeah can't pick a Netflix
film yeah yes yeah yeah that I'm
replacing I believe Amy Poehler from
wine country okay we have the Napa
Valley romp fine luxury cousin and
Godzilla king of the monsters we've
heard Godzilla first Dan whenever you're
ready Kate king of the monsters who's
not oh my god can you imagine the one
problem that the Godzilla came the
monsters had is that by the end of it
you're like I've seen this I would never
get tired of Nicolas Cage meeting Rodin
and the bombed-out remnants of Boston
with the atomic oh my god think I could
possibly imagine in the summer movie and
that we would be 500 times more
interesting we kind of have seen Cage
play the monster play larger than life
and we've seen old-school Japanese uh
Godzilla movies where it is just a guy
in a suit fighting a giant lizard in a
suit it's not that cool whereas wine
country you need that wild card this was
such a dull movie with so many great
comedic talents and you need someone to
stir the pot and kick things up a notch
this was not a this film was less than
the sum of its parts so you needed
someone to to really Nicolas Cage will
not be in a suit he will be Nicholas
Cage himself fighting the monsters so
won't be man and suit it will be
Nicholas Cage fighting and a cab at
comedy was plus one good actor isn't
gonna save the whole comedy Nicolas Cage
he single-handedly replaced guts on
you're gonna get that all the Godzilla
fans coming after you hardcore like they
came after us for making fun of their
precious franchise Nic Cage in wine
country
you get Nick Cage plus alcohol you get
him eight bottles if she believes deep
he's gonna murder
alright which of these movies is gonna
get a little more Bangkok dangerous
Mark Ellis
take it away brother yeah Dan really had
me from the word go the whole Nicolas
Cage replacing Godzilla I was like I am
so locked into this movie I cannot wait
to see this
but then listening to Spencer's argument
it kind of seemed like he's accurate in
the fact that like I am a Godzilla fan
and I if I go pay because he got silly
king of the monsters and Nic Cage has
replaced Godzilla I I was going to the
movie to see the giant lizard not to see
Nicholas Cage make a fool of himself
with wine country I think that Nicolas
Cage could actually add something to
that it was missing so I think making
the movie better dance would have been
funny would have been different but I
think that Spencer made his movie better
so I'm giving the vote to dispense
omeone for Spenny lon I got a disagree
with Marco this would I feel like you
put Nicolas Cage a little white country
and it's just it's an ensemble piece
he's just gonna suck up all the energy
and all those other great comedians
they're not gonna get their chance to
sort of play where as a huge enormous
monster size Nicolas Cage just smashing
that a lot of a city I don't meet
another character I don't need another
scenario I would watch that for two
hours I'm going with that all right lon
wants to leave some room for on a gas
tire Danielle Radford
I haven't recently seen both of these
movies in preparations are today
sometimes things got handy so I have to
agree that with if you put Nicolas Cage
in wine country he does wind up taking
over everything whereas in Godzilla his
job is to take over everything plus I
would get to see ice cubes kid be like
oh he got something going on with Mothra
I know they need that so I have to go
with Nicolas Cage for sometimes oh did I
tell you it's none of my heads since
what why you're judging yes is Ken
Watanabe a design guys seen them the old
music group the monkeys their movie head
yes there was yeah there was a giant of
Victor Mature he's an actor from like
the 50's I just was thinking of giant
shouldn't we suddenly more thanks for
watching 60s drug flashbacks of Dan well
played and a weird fun movie by Dan I
love to ask you this who's taken this
weekend's box-office
Oh it chapter 2 pound wise is gonna
gonna eat your children and all of the
money oh yeah you're going to wrong any
other thoughts shoutouts no I've hope a
fun to do the show I hope I know weird
monthly now but it's longer and I hope
you enjoyed it we look forward to coming
back and about another months time I
think we're thinking about a Joker
centered around Joker type wait what's
gonna be twisted but in homage
Spencer awesome stuff
funny knowledgeable what do any what he
got what do you shout out Jared Leto's
Joker man gone too soon I feel like we
only just begun I got nothing right on
thank you sir mark you're the best
yummy uh Stan updates coming up the
scoreboard indicates otherwise Hellmuth
now yeah I'm gonna be the comedy store
on sunset right here in Los Angeles
September 12 Thursday shows at 8 p.m.
you get tickets at Mark Ellis live.com a
bunch of funny people surprise droppings
maybe somebody that is teaming up with a
wrestler for an upcoming movie aren't
gonna pop in what are the Markel a
stand-up show very possibly
that's awesome please go see Mark Ellis
and friends lawn Harris and Daniel
Radford two awesome people on what's
going on tell them where they can find
you and what not it's funny on Twitter
oh that's it
oh hell yeah it's all I got Daniel rat
burger um yeah yeah find me at Daniel
Radford on Twitter Daniel underscore
Radford on Instagram still trying to get
those things so I can start getting my
free fat lady clothes help me help me
help this woman help me help me get me
more dresses and then that's it and if
you like wrestling I have a wrestling
podcast called types of fights comes out
every Thursday heck yeah
Thank You Danielle I got a shout out my
pal Joe star thank you for kicking it
off and Thank You Ryan
Thank You JT and Thank You owl nation
hoot hoot I'm Hal Rudnick I hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at Hal Rudnick and
thank you for watching movie fights
buddy
you